haha the Joe Rogan experience that's how
I ended up meeting Mikey bouche Ettie
who is now Artie Lange's hey how's
already doing is he doing I checked his
you know what I said he was suffering
from anxiety anxiety yeah I went when I
went to New York I was scheduled to his
podcast that Wednesday and he canceled
he's not using he's not using no he did
a podcast with me at the Legion of
skanks place and it was amazing
he was great it was great to see him
sober and so so alert present so they're
so honest and [ __ ] hilarious he's
like as funny as he's ever been [ __ ]
up knows laughing about it doesn't know
the [ __ ] talking about what he did he
snorted glass snorted glass his girl
broke up these pills with a [ __ ] a
salt shaker and cracked it and got glass
in snorted glasses nose is bleeding
and he also got knocked out by a guy who
he owed money to guy who he owed money
to hired some kid to collect and the guy
punched him in the nose and smashed his
nose and so he had a double whammy
happened two things at the same time
smoking a snorting glass and then that
brute dude he was so funny he was so
funny and he was so alert it was great
it was like the RDI I knew years ago but
even better like I don't think I've ever
known Artie so you know the circle of
there's a circle it's a spiraling out of
control you get involved mmm when you
when you're going through it you're not
seeing it
yeah once you've done it and you have
the balls and you look back they're all
hilarious I went through it they're all
hilarious but you just keep getting in
trouble
isn't it funny though that that's a
human turn it's a fight it's a funny
pattern there's so many humans falling
walk with heroin Group 86 garage the
cops came down it's things that would
never ever happen under
ulis circumstances but the funk of the
drug it just hits you at one time where
remember that everything listen nobody
drives to an open mic with a Lamborghini
you know right you never seen nobody
pull up to an open mic a Lamborghini
nobody does cocaine everyone the second
time does they had a bad time doing it
right you do have a really good time at
first or it seems like you having a good
time your body left an opening somewhere
mm-hmm you know just how are your immune
system did letting her on of it then
sometimes your soul just has a weakness
somewhere and that's when the coke or
the heroin comes in mm-hmm I know is
mine
really but how crazy was I caught up in
this [ __ ] so then he went down this
[ __ ] just hole you know and that's
what rehabs do they catch you they slow
you up they try to identify the problem
with him was this father was it the
firing of of you know the radio guy no
he had the problems way before that he
had problems when he was on MADtv what
set him right you know that's what the
rehab does you know that's what we what
sets you the [ __ ] off and you gotta get
yourself away from that I found that
what set me off over the years you know
there was a time that could sit here for
hours II talk I'm out on bail and I'm
[ __ ] I don't bail kidnapping come on
bail for second-degree kidnapping
second-degree assault you know I'm I got
the worst roll at me and I'm [ __ ]
going in to see as I read that and
clipping tensed Bruce Springsteen
double-set CDs born in the USA they're
gone for $80 whatever they were gone for
$40 I'm getting 22 apiece I'm taking two
a day I'm walking with the small 220 I
got a hundred for Coke 54 weed and 50
for lunch that was it
I still remember like doing this for a
month like just like my addiction add me
on this schedule that I wasn't gonna
work well I'm hot I'm bail I'm gonna
show the Sears Roebuck everyday and Rob
warm by the USA they even had him right
by the door I don't even have to do much
work I just had a walk in walk into
Sears may believe I was looking for a
hammer and then on the way out I just
take a have four of them put on my shirt
and walk up one day Joe I'm gonna pick
up like ten of them because instead of
four take four it's like the guy says in
narco you're gonna move a kilo you might
as well move to you're gonna move to you
might as well move five you're gonna
move five you might as well do ten
what's the difference so instead of
taking four boxes I started taking like
tens like I would walk out of there Joe
Rogan like a CD [ __ ] thing and when
that wall got in here we go hey you stop
right there and I'm like what are you
talking about he's like come back with
those CDs they're chasing me in Boulder
mm-hmm in the parking lot of Crossroads
Mall Here I am getting chased one
security guard in the car
and the other guy on foot I could beat
them both up by the way like I could
beat them [ __ ] or both of them but I
just can't have no problems so what am i
doing I'm whipping two CDs at him as I'm
running and the guy said hey stop that I
finally quit them what made me think I
was gonna get away the police is coming
right at me
and I have a stop and give him a fake
name and [ __ ] you know hearing him
out on [ __ ] bail why am i robbing
[ __ ] see why we addicted to it to the
thrill I was addicted to snorting coke
and getting my dick so do you think
there's a little bit of an addiction to
the thrill of stealing - oh I loved all
that cuz you loved all that doing that
[ __ ] later on with like lighters and
[ __ ]
oh I loved all that [ __ ] if I'm not in
trouble for something listen I just
smoked three joints were you here don't
look either you
now you look fine don't do not no more
well it gets you in a good place but the
Refik lets me know I'm still nothing has
changed about me where I could be in a a
right now I'm be clean and sober I don't
do enough to warrant being [ __ ] on
sober mm-hmm this just lets me know I'm
okay it's like a teddy bear it's like
when people suck that though that's all
this is from me reef and now it doesn't
really get me blasted no more
[Applause]